the houses today provided a clear
majority against leaving without a deal
however I will repeat what I have said
before
[Applause]
the other house was calm itself long
time to go today subsequent days Keep
Calm it's the Prime Minister's
festivities these are about the choices
that this house faces the legal default
the legal default in UK and EU law
remains that the UK will leave the EU
without a deal unless unless something
else is agreed the onus is now on every
one of us in this house to find out what
that is the options before us are the
same as they always have been we could
leave we could leave with the deal which
this government is negotiations in the
past two years we could leave with the
deal we have negotiated but subject to a
second referendum but that would risk no
brexit at all
damaging damaging the fragile trust
between the British
[Applause]
damaging damaging the fragile trust
between the British public and the
members of this house we could seek to
negotiate a different deal however the
EU has been clear that the deal on the
table is indeed the only deal available
mr. speaker I also confirmed last night
the great likelihood I await further
comment but I think I can say this
without fear of contradiction is there
will be further opportunities for these
matters to be debated in the immediate
term please let us have some courtesy of
that I think we can be sure there will
be further debate on these matters the
Prime Minister Mr Speaker I also
confirmed last night that if the House
declined to approve leaving without a
deal on the 29th of March 2019 the
government would bring forward a motion
on whether the house supports seeking to
agree in extension to article 50 with
the EU which is the logical consequence
of the votes over the past two days in
this house the leader of the house will
shortly make an emergency business
statement confirming the change to
tomorrow's business the motion we will
table was set out the fundamental choice
facing this house if the house finds a
way in the coming days to support a deal
it would allow the government to seek a
short limited technical extension to
article 50 to provide time to pass the
necessary legislation and ratify the
agreement we have reached with the EU
but let me be clear such a short
technical extension is only likely to be
on offer if we have a deal in place
therefore the house has to understand
and upset that if it is not willing to
support a deal in the coming days and as
it is not willing to support leaving
without a deal on the 29th of March then
it is suggesting that there will need to
be a much longer extension to article 50
such an extension would undoubtedly
require the United Kingdom to hold
European Parliament elections
[Applause]
i I I do not think that would be the
right outcome but the house the house
needs to face up to the consequences
[Applause]